a lot of the discussion of the
succession opening credits focuses on
finding easter eggs or hidden secrets
that point to the show's future plot but
i think that framing sells the opening
short because not only has executive
producer adam mckay denied hiding
anything in the opening i think the true
genius of the opening is hidden in plain
sight many have noticed the opening
similarities with the opening of david
fincher's the game which also features
home video footage a rich family party
and an absent workaholic father the
succession intro does seem at least
partially inspired by this one and i
will say if you're gonna copy a
director's opening title sequence
fincher is definitely the right choice
but succession's opening does more than
just borrow from the game succession
twists the classic nostalgic montage by
showing the core emotional issues
underpinning the entire show
the intro doesn't just use old-timey
footage it mixes that footage with
modern footage like when we see the new
york skyline during different eras the
mixing of styles and time periods gets
more creative in this shot when we cut
from an old timey camera to not an
old-timey scene but rather a modern news
anchor these cuts are a simple yet
classic example of montage by pairing
two similar images from different time
periods the intro creates a feeling of
dynasty of a media corporation that
spans across space and time and it
creates an association between the life
of the roy family and the life of their
business but linking up these two worlds
also has a more sinister effect some
online have pointed out the inaccuracy
of the old footage in the first place
technically since the three younger roy
children were born in the 80s they
should have used videotape footage for
their childhood instead of the more
antiquated film stock but i think that
choice improves the opening it has the
obvious effect of making the family
dynasty feel even older but filmstock
also typically adds nostalgia movies
like martin scorsese's mean streets use
eight millimeter film stock to show
simpler more familiar times but
succession bastardizes this trope by
using film stock for distinctly
unsentimental moments unlike the game
whose opening has some bittersweet
moments succession's home footage just
feels cold the kids do expensive things
alone without their other siblings and
many shots show their expansive backyard
physically separating the family from
each other these images remain
consistent even as the opening changes
between seasons season 2 adds the
videotape look to show the kids as young
adults and in that similarly nostalgic
style characters look unhappy and
distant the opening shows a childhood
filled not with fond memories but with
the unfulfilling excesses of wall street
the shots of corporate buildings don't
just show the family's power they also
taint the home footage and we lose that
charming nostalgia we normally associate
with film stock and videotape the result
is a world with a strange mix of
business and pleasure a world where a
dad can hold a business meeting in the
same space his children play one shot
cuts seamlessly from a dining table to a
business contract as if those two things
are one in the same this strange
dichotomy actually foreshadows the
conflict that kicks off the entire show
in the pilot kendall leaves work to go
to his dad's 80th birthday party but his
dad doesn't see that as a good thing he
sees it as a sign that kendall's not fit
to lead the company you left the room
the deal to come to my dad's [ __ ]
birthday party logan doesn't respect
kendall because kendall doesn't do what
logan did in the opening credits hold a
meeting instead of spending time with
his family in a cruel reversal of family
life and business life logan would have
respected kendall moore if he had been a
ruthless businessman instead of a family
man and the only way he'll respect you
is if you try to destroy him because in
your position that is exactly what he
would try to do but the opening does
much more than predict specific plot
elements more importantly it unlocks the
deep trauma within the roy children the
opening is crucial to understanding the
roy kids especially because it's the
only time we actually see them as
children just like our memories of our
own childhood theirs is a series of
snapshots we see logan roy from their
subjective point of view he is almost
always faceless and uninvolved walking
away and having his back towards them
he's not a father he's only a patriarch
and this idea gets confirmed in the show
the opening credits really are their
only memories of their dad they can't
think of anything intimate what's
something special that you and your dad
enjoy doing together no
next question and their father's
obsession with business over family has
poisoned his kids mind to the point that
they can't tell the difference between
genuine care and a calculated business
decision what is this what's the angle
no angle
we're worried but that is their world
whether or not the family gets along has
real world financial consequences and
the show is full of moments that are
both personal and professional so that
idea anchors many of the dramatic
moments not just in the opening credits
but throughout the show it could also
make the show hilarious i love you and i
i'm glad you're part of my life but i am
taking legal action against you there's
also a meta element to the ideas
explored in the opening credits pretty
much every studio is throwing money at
various shows to try to make the next
game of thrones some epic fantasy
blockbuster with an enormous budget but
with succession hbo has ironically
created a hit that feels like the polar
opposite the show has few special
effects there are no sudden deaths and
most characters don't change much
throughout the show succession feels
like a shakespearean play it's a tale as
old as time a tale of dynasty power and
family succession is a show literally
about how a big budget is not enough to
satisfy us what matters most is the
tried and true formula of exploring the
complicated relationships between
interesting characters and as a guy who
also has three siblings i can confirm
that you don't need a billion dollars to
have an insane family it's actually
surprisingly affordable so maybe other
studios can learn a lesson from
succession and its opening credits but
until then i'll be here waiting for
season four listening to that amazing
soundtrack over and over again
[Music]
if you liked taking a closer look at
succession's opening credits then i have
some great videos to recommend there's
an entire series analyzing the opening
credits for dozens of different tv shows
each video is done by a different
youtuber including some of my favorites
like patrick h willems h bomberguy and
just right i even made one for the
simpsons you can watch all these videos
on nebula a streaming service you've
probably already heard of that has no
ads and exclusive content from
educational youtubers you love including
me and right now we've partnered with
curiositystream to give you the brand
new smart bundle a bundle which gives
you access to six amazing educational
streaming platforms curiosity stream
nebula some tv tastemade topic and one
day university all for less than four
dollars a month when you get a year
subscription that gets you the opening
credits series on nebula plus tons of
other educational videos covering
hundreds of genres you can get access to
this incredible deal by going to
smartbundle.com now you see it sb and
using the gift code now you see it sb at
checkout this is a great last minute
christmas present for anybody looking to
explore their curiosity thank you to
curiositystream for sponsoring this
video and a big thank you to my patreon
supporters i couldn't do this without
you thanks for watching